SPEAKER: If you
are an enterprise,
chances are you have
networking, storage, and compute
on multiple clouds and
in your own data center.
How can you consistently secure
and operate existing apps,
develop and deploy
the new apps across
those disparate locations?
How can you get centralized
visibility and management
of those resources?
Well, that is why Anthos exists.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Anthos 101.
As an enterprise,
it is very common
to have an existing
networking, storage,
and compute on multiple clouds
and in your own data centers.
On each of these platforms you
need to manage infrastructure.
Let's say you use
containers on the clouds
and develop apps using services
on Google Cloud and AWS.
Regardless of platform, you
will need policy enforcement
across your IT footprint.
To manage these
across platforms,
you need monitoring
and logging systems,
and you need to
integrate that data
into meaningful categories,
like business data,
operational data, and alerts.
Digging further, you might use
operational data and alerts
to inform optimizations,
automations,
and to set policies or SLOs.
You might use business
data to do all those things
and to deploy third-party apps.
Then, to actually enact the
changes you've decided on,
you need to act on different
specific parts of the system.
That means digging into each
tool for policy enforcement,
securing services, orchestrating
containers, and managing
infrastructure management.
Oh, and don't forget,
all of this work
is in addition to what it
takes to develop and deploy
your own apps.
Now, consider repeating
this set of tasks and data
across a hybrid and
multi-cloud landscape.
It becomes very, very
complex very quickly.
Your platform
admins, SREs, DevOps
who are responsible for
security and efficiency
have manual cluster by cluster
management, data collection,
and information synthesis.
With this complexity,
it's hard to stay current,
to understand
business implications,
and to ensure compliance,
not to mention the difficulty
onboarding a new hire.
Anthos helps solve
these challenges.
With Anthos, you
get a consistent way
to manage with similar
infrastructure management,
container management, service
management, and policy
enforcement across
your platform.
As a result, you
gain observability
across your platforms
in one single place,
including business
information, alerts,
and operational information.
With this information, you might
decide to optimize, automate,
and set policies
or SLOs, or might
rely on our machine
learning models
to make automated suggestions.
You take those recommendations
or make your own decisions
and apply them to different
management layers.
Simple, right?
Not quite.
You may have different regions
that need different policies
and also have different
development, staging,
or production environments that
need different permissions.
Some parts of your work
may need more security.
That's where environs come in.
Environs are the way
to create logical sets
of underlying
Kubernetes clusters,
regardless of which platform
these clusters live on.
By considering grouping
and managing sets
of clusters as
logical environs, you
can think about and work
with your applications
at the right level of detail
for what you need to do,
be it business insights
over the entire system,
setting for a dev environment,
or troubleshooting
data for a specific cluster.
Using environs, each part
of the functional stack
can take declarative
direction about configuration,
compliance, and more.
Anthos provides platform
administrators a single place
to monitor and manage their
landscape, including policy
control and marketplace access.
This reduces person hours
in management, enforcement,
discovery, and communication.
Anthos also provides them an
out-of-the-box structured view
of their entire system,
including services, clusters,
and more, simplifying their
view and management so they can
improve security, use
resources more efficiently,
and demonstrate
measurable success.
Anthos is also a
platform to modernize
application development.
Why?
Because it uses environs to
enforce policies and processes
and abstracts away that cluster
and container management
from the application teams.
Anthos allows you to
easily abstract away
infrastructure from
application teams
by making it easy for
them to incorporate
a wide variety of CICD
solutions on top of environs,
allowing you to view and
manage your applications
at the right level of detail.
Here are the key components
of Anthos delivering
the capabilities we discussed.
Anthos simplifies and
provides a consistent view
across your company's
landscape so you
can improve security, use
resources more efficiently,
innovate faster, and
demonstrate measurable success.
Now, that's a pretty
high-level overview of Anthos.
In the next video,
we will show you
how to get started with
Anthos on Google Cloud.
Until then, like, subscribe,
and follow the links below
to learn more about Anthos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]